i know it's a tough question something
that springs to mind about physics for
example that just is beautiful i mean
right from the beginning say special
relativity was a big surprise
uh you know most of us have a simple
concept of time and it seems perfectly
adequate for everything we've ever seen
and to have it explained to you that you
need to sort of have a mixture concept
of time and space where you put it into
the space-time construct how it looks
different from different perspectives
that was quite a shock
and that was
you know such a shock that it makes you
think what else do i know that you know
isn't the way it seems certainly quantum
mechanics is certainly another enormous
shock in terms of from your point you
know you have this idea that there's a
space and then there's you know
point particles at points and maybe
fields in between
and um quantum mechanics is just a whole
different representation it looks
nothing like what you would have thought
as sort of the basic representation of
of the physical world and that was quite
a surprise what would you say is the
catalyst
for the for the view quake in in
theoretical physics in the 20th century
what where does that come from so the
interesting thing about einstein it
seems like a lot of that came from like
almost thought experiments it wasn't
almost experimentally driven
um and with actually i don't
know
the full story of quantum mechanics how
much of it is experiment like where
if you look at the full trace of idea
generation there
of all the weird stuff that falls out of
quantum mechanics how much of that was
the experimentalist how much was it the
theoreticians but usually in theoretical
physics the theories lead the way so
maybe can you uh
can you elucidate like what what is the
catalyst for these
the remarkable thing about physics and
about many other areas of academic
intellectual life is that it just seems
way over determined that is
if it hadn't been for einstein or if it
hadn't been for heisenberg certainly
within a half a century somebody else
would have come up with essentially the
same things
is that something you believe or is that
something yes so i think when you look
at sort of just the history of physics
and the history of other areas you know
some areas like that there's just this
enormous convergence
that the the different kind of evidence
that was being collected
was
so redundant in the sense that so many
different things revealed the same
things that eventually you just kind of
have to accept it because it just gets
obvious
so if you look at the details of course
you know
einstein did it for somebody else and
it's well worth celebrating einstein for
that and you know we by celebrating the
particular people who did something
first or came across something first we
were encouraging all the rest to move a
little faster
to try to to push us all a little faster
which is great
but
i still think we would have gotten
roughly to the same place within half
centuries so
sometimes people are special because of
how much longer it would have taken so
some people say general relativity would
have taken longer without einstein than
other things i mean
heisenberg quantum mechanics i mean
there were several different
formulations of quantum mechanics all
around the same few years
means no one of them made that much of a
difference we would have had pretty much
the same thing regardless of which of
them did it exactly when
nevertheless i'm happy to celebrate them
all but this is a choice i make in my
research that is when there's an area
where there's lots of people working
together you know who are sort of
scoping each other and getting getting a
result just before somebody else does
you ask well how much of a difference
would i make there
at most i could make something happen a
few months before somebody else and so
i'm less worried about them missing
things so when i'm trying to help the
world like doing research i'm looking
for neglected things i'm looking for
things that nobody's doing it if i
didn't do it nobody would do it
nobody would do it or at least in the
next time 20 years kind of thing exactly
same with general relativity just you
know who would do it
it might take another 10 20 30 50 years
so that's the place where you can have
the biggest impact is finding the things
that nobody would do unless you did them
and then that's when you get the big
view quake the insight
you